what we're going to do in this video is
try to look at as many scenarios as we
can where an object is exhibiting
uniform circular motion it's traveling
around in a circle at a constant speed
and what we want to do is think about
why it's staying on the circle what
centripetal force is keeping the object
from just going off in a straight line
so in this first scenario i have some
type of a wheel maybe a ball attached to
a string that is attached to a peg at
the center of the table
and this wheel is moving in a circle at
a constant speed so it's moving in this
circle at a constant speed
so pause this video think about all of
the forces that are acting on this wheel
and which of those forces or maybe some
combination of those forces that are
actually acting as the centripetal force
that are keeping the wheel on the circle
all right now let's work through this
together so there's a couple of forces
that aren't impacting the wheels staying
on the circle so much but they're there
for example you're definitely going to
have the force of gravity we're assuming
we're dealing with this wheel on a
planet so
that would will denote its magnitude as
capital f sub g
and then this is its direction with this
orange arrow so that's the force of
gravity and the reason why the the wheel
is not accelerating downward is that we
have that table there and so the table
is exerting a
normal force on the wheel that
counteracts the gravitational force
so the magnitude there would be the
force
the normal force and these are going to
be the same magnitude they're just going
to be in different directions and so let
me see if i can draw this arrow a little
bit taller
but what else is going on
well as you can imagine if the string
wasn't here the wheel really would go
off at a straight line and eventually
fall off of the table and so the string
is providing some inward force that
keeps the the wheel going in a circle
and that inward force that pulling force
we would consider that to be the tension
force so i'll just
draw it like that and its magnitude is f
sub t
and in this situation it is providing
that inward force so that is the
centripetal force so we could say the
magnitude of the tension the tension
force the pulling force is going to be
equal to the centripetal force in this
case they're actually the exact same
vector so i can even write it i can even
write it like this this is the
centripetal force vector it's the
tension in that rope that keeps us going
in a circle let's do another example
so this one is similar but i have a few
more dimensions going on here this is a
classic example from physics i have a
string attached to the ceiling and i
have some type of a ball or a pendulum
and it's swinging in a circular
in a circular motion right over here at
a constant speed so the center of its
circle would be right around there so
once again pause this video think about
all of the forces on that ball and we're
not going to talk too much about air
resistance let's assume that these are
in vacuum chambers for now and then
think about well which of those forces
is providing the centripetal force
well just like in the last video there's
definitely some force of gravity so you
have
that vector right over there and so its
magnitude is f sub g
and you also have the string holding up
the ball and so
you're going to have its pulling force
on
so this would be
the magnitude here would be f sub t this
is the tension force
but what's counteracting the gravity and
what's keeping us going in a circle
well in this situation we can think
about the different components of the
tension because this is going off at an
angle so if we break down that vector
in the vertical direction so
if we take the vertical component or the
y component of the tension force
it would look something like this we
could call that f t
y for the y component this would be its
magnitude and that is what is
counteracting the gravity why the ball
is not accelerating downwards and if we
think about the x component of the
tension
that would be this right over here
this is the x component of the tension
just to be clear where i'm getting this
from so this would be f
tension in the x direction that would be
its magnitude and that is what is
providing the centripetal force or that
is the centripetal force so in this
syste in this situation
the component of our tension in the x
direction and let me just denote that as
a vector
that is our that is our centripetal
force that's what keeps the ball from
just going straight off in a direction
like that